わぁ゛ぁ゛       バカもう
ハッハッハ⤴︎
ハッハッハ⤵︎
ぇ もーーー
ヤベーこれ帰りてえ.. 待ってヤバイ 人来た人来た     キタァ？
怖い怖い    びっくりしたなんで     え、まって エッ人が来た
怖い怖い怖い   何何何何何何何何何何何何何    怖い怖い怖い
プーン ETCカードが.....
エッびっくりした え、終わったかと思った
蔵原トンネル行かれるんですよねぇ？そこを 旧なんですけど
そこつい最近まで開いてたところなんで
旧の旧の蔵原トンネルがホントにヤバイところ
エッ 通行止めってなってたとこ...
アッコは ここ2、3年前まで通れてたんでそんなに大したことないんですけど
右側の方ににちょっと獣道みたいなんがあるんですけど
そこを登ってくと
なんかちょっと崩落したような
今おひまですか？   うーんまぁひまですけど...     なんか道だけ教えていただいても.    あぁーいいですよ
すいません、、ありがとうございます
じゃあちょっとついて来てもらって
やっぱすげぇなぁ  なんか流れが来てますねぇ
はじめくんもってる もってる
そう コンビニの店員さん
よくわかりましたねぇ すごいなぁ
ひぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇ////////////////⤴︎⤴︎⤴︎やばいやばいやばいww
お気をつけて、俺らかw
すいませんありがとうございました
帰りお気をつけて
はい。というわけで服装をチェンジしたので
早速これでいこうと思います。
行こうぜっ
うわっうわっ 何何何   クモックゥモッ
よくそんな...行けますね      俺結構怖いっすよ
確かに、     静かにしてると熊来ちゃうから
逆に騒ぎながら行ったほうがいいっす     うわぁぁぁっ    行きます
とぅわぁぁっ
えぇぇぇぇ
一同ビビる
大丈夫
待って ホント危ないないマジで危ない
気をつけて   はい      痛い痛い痛い痛い
ホントだ開けた  めっちゃ開けました
え、本当だ！
間違いないっす  マジで近い！
はい   道路がある時点でまだ可能性は
マジだ  ホントに声出すの正解
君の手っで~
切り裂いて〜
遠い日の
記憶を
悲しみの
息の根を止めてくれよ
さあ愛に焦がれた胸を貫け
もぉぉぉぉぉ     もぉぉぉぉ    もぉぉぉぉぉ
待って なになになにホント怖い
マジでなに
う゛う゛う゛んん             う゛う゛う゛んん                 う゛う゛う゛んん
う゛う゛う゛                  うわぁ゛ぁ゛ぁ゛ぁぁぁまってぇぇぇぇ
なになになになになになになに
ほんっと怖い
どうしたんすか なんか鳴った？
ガーサガサッて聞こえたでしょ      めっちゃでかい音してました今
う゛う゛う゛んn   う゛う゛う゛んn       う゛う゛う゛んn
あうぅぅぅ
うわぁぁぁあぁぁぁっぁ
＠＄＆＾＠＃b      え、何ですか？        なに今の？
わかんないす デカかったっす   デカイデカイホントでかい
待ってヤバイ  マジでヤバイ
声出してぇ゛ぇ゛
はい    はぃはぃははいっはいはいはいひ
マジでマジで走ってなかったら死んでた
重いのがいた今
ぷぴぽぴぷぴぽぴぷぴぽぴぷぴぽぴ
たーーたらららーりー たらららーーたらららーりー
たらららーーたーたっらー  たらららーらーらー    たったったったっ